what's up gulan the genv Twitter page
has just released a preview trailer for
episode 5 and I had some time on my
hands and thought why not take a look at
what could be in store now I apologize
for the quality since this is ripped
from Twitter but I'll leave a link to
the post below so you can check it out
and come on back and just a reminder I'm
covering the entire season so make sure
you're subscribed with the Bell on for
when all my genv videos Drop here's
Jordan telling us there are days that
he's missing so it seems like it's not
just Marie who's having these big chunks
of her memory missing could every
student at good can be affected by this
I mean we've seen how the entire dorms
are basically fitted to be prisons with
metal doors and steel plates that
descend over the windows note the wall
behind Jordan the sexy Starlight poster
and neon female figure suggest this
could be some sort of frat house in the
red band trailer we'll see an eagle neon
sign and a fire breather with red flip
cups in front of him but we can't 100%
confirm this is the same house later on
we'll see these red flip cups dangling
behind Sam and in the season trailer
we'll see Roff is blasted through a
similar looking house by a keg we'll see
that this is done by Jordan but Andre
comes in and pins him to the wall with
some garden shears and this levitating
shovel here's Emma waking up in some
sort of tub but there's part of me that
thinks she actually might be in her big
mode here and this is her in an actual
pool this stonework and blue pool lining
suggests this but she could simply be in
a regular pool or a hot tub some tea
likely prepared by Dean shett in episode
2 we saw how she prepared tea for Marie
and in episode three she even made her
pancakes I think it's a long shot but we
can't just rule out that she may be
putting something in her food or drink
this shot also reminds me of get out
where the mother would do the same
circular movement in her teacup to put
Daniel Kia's character into a trance
notice the nails here these seem to be
the same Nails found in the first look
trailer next to a crying Andre I think
this is Dean Shetty and she may be
hiding either a superpower or some drug
that is causing this Mar looking quite
concerned alongside Jordan looks like
these two are in the same boat re e
memory loss and when Jordan mentions
this to Andre and Kate Kate says she's
missing memories too no word on if Andre
is experiencing this too I wouldn't be
surprised if he's not considering his
dad is one of the trusty members and
wouldn't want his son's memory messed
with here's Emma looking pretty
concerned walking through the gulan
dorms in a gulan sweater but what's up
with this big rip at the back we'll also
see her alongside Marie wearing the same
s maybe she had to put this on after her
clothes ripped from her turning big
check out Rufus running the hell away
the only person I could see him running
away from at the moment is Marie who
blew up his dick but he kind of looks
fine I definitely wouldn't be at school
the day after my dick exploded so this
calls into question what we saw last
episode was it even real he did say
after all that this isn't what it looks
like looks like Sam has calmed down
after almost killing Dr cardosa last
episode I'm guessing this is Emma who
he's talking to saying that there are
evil people at gulan the background
looks as though it could have a pool in
it maybe that's where we'll find Emma
later here we see a shovel blasting past
Jordan and Marie by checking the other
trailer footage it seems as though
Jordan blasts Rufus through a wall with
a cake Jordan and Marie go to question
him then Andre comes in and throws
garden shears and a shovel at him
although the exact order of these things
may change take note of Marie's red top
and Jordan's blue jacket in the red band
trailer we'll see them wearing the same
thing in a forest with this dude in a
green bathroom who is this guy he looks
pretty darn young in the season ahead
trailer we'll see him at the frat house
where Kate awakens from some sort of
dream before she is teleported is he the
one doing the teleporting it definitely
could be considering the others seem to
jump when Kate disappears while he
remains calm Emma watches on as Marie
uses her blood power to reveal this
protrusion could Marie and the other
students have been given implants or
trackers without their knowledge Marie
will tell Kate that she thinks Dean
shett is behind this this is followed by
an actual shot of the dean down in the
woods with potentially Dr cardosa beside
her we know from the other trailers that
we're going to see several more
experiments down here here's Sam taking
on a bunch of Puppets but as these shots
would suggest these are actually people
whose Sam schizophrenia has turned them
into looking like puppets this is what
Sam sees in his mind they come at him
with machine guns and Swinging From
helicopters and that's pretty much it
for the trailer so now I turn it over to
you what do you think will happen in
episode 5 I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe I'll be covering the entire
season you can also follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstory YT until
next time remember holy
a lot is
happening